Hi, everyone. I'm Clive Loseby
and I am passionate
about changing the world,
one website at a time.
As Dale said I was
in a bad car crash a long time ago.
It left us all
with life-changing injuries.
And that's why accessibility
and website accessibility
has become my passion.
The accident also left me
with a very bad memory,
so please forgive me
if I keep looking at my notes.
OK. Does everybody know
what a cookie banner is?
Those annoying banners
that pop up on a website
asking for consent
to put cookies into your browser?
It may say something like,
"This website uses cookies
to give you the best online experience.
Follow this link to confirm
that you consent to this.”
Does everyone know what I'm talking about?
(Audience: Yes!)
Good. Right, now I want you to imagine
a different kind of browser.
This one says the following:
"This website is designed
for white people only.
Follow this link
to confirm that you are white."
Or, "This website is for men only.
Follow this link
to confirm that you are a man."
Or, "This website
is for straight people only.
Follow this link to confirm
that you are straight."
Or even, "This website
is for people who have hair.
Follow this link
to confirm you have hair."
OK.
These don't happen in the real world,
but what I do need to tell you about
is another banner that does exist
on over 97% of the world's websites.
"This website is for people
who are not disabled.
Follow this link to confirm
that you are not disabled."
This may not be as apparent
as the cookie banner.
Believe me, this banner exists.
Ninety-seven point four percent
of 1 million website home pages
tested last year
had detectable accessibility failures.
So how many disabled people
are there in the world?
In 2010, the World Health Organization
estimated that 1 billion
people on the planet
live with some form of disability,
with over 110 million having highly
significant difficulties in functioning.
We are talking about a lot of people.
They also would like to use
the web as much as you or I do.
They also want to become your customers
and spend money with you,
if you make it possible for them to do so.
The title of this talk is a direct quote
from somebody I met last year.
She works in health, safety,
employee well-being
and has done for 20 years,
so she has a real understanding
of inclusivity.
Lovely, caring person,
but she just could not understand
how blind people could use the internet
because they couldn't see the screen.
I explained to her
what a screen reader was
and she got it.
A screen reader, by the way,
is a piece of software
that reads out the content of a website
using a computerized voice.
If you're blind, you can't use a mouse
because you can't see where to put it.
So you will use your keyboard instead
in conjunction with the screen reader.
It's not that easy to do
but cookie banners
make life so much worse.
And in some cases,
they actually prevent blind people
from accessing the website beyond it.
We are in the year 2022.
The first set of guidelines for websites
to help ensure that they met
the needs of disabled people
were released quite recently,
actually, in 1999.
A mere 23 years ago.
Yep. I'm not joking.
All the information has been available
to everyone since then.
It is also a legal requirement
in most countries,
but above everything else,
it helps every business
and every organization
become more inclusive.
And yet, 97% of websites
contained detectable
accessibility failures last year.
Think of a website as a building,
it becomes even more obvious.
After all, websites are
physical buildings.
They're your window
on the world, aren't they?
Legislation for access
to physical buildings
has always made allowances
for very old buildings
where it's simply not possible
to make them fully accessible
for people with disabilities.
We all understand that.
So actually, I think it's perfectly fair
that you shouldn't expect
a website over 23 years old
to cater for disabled people either.
I'm actually not sure
the last time I went on a website
that was over 23 years old.
But what about five years old
or about three years old?
What about last year? This year?
Typically, websites get replaced
every three to five years
as a new one is built
to cater for the latest trends.
Is it really OK that websites
that are recently built
are still inaccessible
for disabled people?
If not now, when?
OK, so what does accessible
web design actually mean?
Please take a look at these doors.
They both go into the same building.
Both sets of doors have level access.
The door on the left slides open
automatically as you approach it.
The doors on the right
have to be pulled open.
I would like to ask you all a question,
and if you are able,
I would like you
to either raise your left hand
or your right hand in answer.
Imagine you're in a wheelchair
and you want to enter this building.
Which of the doors do you think
you would be most likely to use?
The automatic doors on the left
or the heavy doors on the right?
Could you please raise your left
or your right hand accordingly?
Well, I think it's fair to say
the consensus is on the left. Interesting.
OK. Now instead of being in a wheelchair,
you're using a walking frame,
so you can walk,
but you need to have both
of your hands on the frame.
Which set of doors do you think
you would be likely to use now?
Could you raise your hands
if you're able to?
I'm really surprised.
Everyone's going left.
OK. Right.
Now you're pushing a child in a pushchair
so you can walk quite normally,
but you've got a pushchair
and both of your hands on it.
Which set of doors now?
Left or right?
I'm staggered.
OK. Final example.
Let's assume that you've actually gone in
through the doors on the right.
You're coming out,
you want to come out the building,
but you've actually got
boxes of files under both arms.
Which of the doors would you go then?
Yeah. Hmm.
I'm really staggered.
In pretty much every example
pretty much everybody
raised your left hand.
Why was this?
After all, you’re free to choose
which door to use at each time.
Why would so many people
go for an automatic door?
Maybe because it's easier.
Nobody's forcing you to use it.
It's there as an alternative
to the other doors.
Accessible web design is exactly the same,
offering people with different needs
alternative ways of using a website
to get the same information.
Most countries around the world
have anti-discrimination laws,
and websites fall under these laws.
However, for me, it's not
about complying with the law.
It is about becoming more inclusive,
more welcoming to everyone,
regardless of their ability
or their disability.
Disabled people have money to spend
on your goods and services
and if they can't spend it with you,
they're going to spend it
with somebody else.
So what should you do
with regard to your own website?
Well, you need to have two things.
You need to have an audit of your website,
and then you need to put
an accessibility statement
on your website.
I'll explain what I mean
in this photograph.
This hotel, it's a beautiful building.
There’s downstairs seating.
There’s upstairs seating.
There's beautiful staircases everywhere,
but unfortunately, there isn't a lift.
The restaurant itself is run
by an outside catering company.
It's not their fault there's no lift.
It's not their building,
they're just renting the space.
However, if you're in a wheelchair,
you can't use the upstairs seating.
But if there was a sign near the entrance
saying something like,
"Patrons in wheelchairs, please note
that although we've got upstairs seating,
we do not have a lift.
However, we do have
some reserved seating for you
with extra turning space
and raised tables."
Think about raised tables.
If you're in a wheelchair and you try
to go into a restaurant anywhere,
you can't quite get under the table.
Easily fixed, just put them on
some small wooden blocks.
Anyway, if you just put up that sign,
somebody in a wheelchair
who reads that sign,
are they going to feel
more or less included?
The cost of doing this is almost nothing,
but the effect is huge.
It's not the catering companies
fault there's no lift.
They've just gone out of their way
to offer an alternative
despite the limitations of the hotel.
In other words,
the catering company themselves
have become more welcoming,
inclusive and accessible.
So the first part of this story
where I explained the restaurant
has upstairs seating, but no lift.
That could be seen as an audit.
"We realize there's no lift
to the upstairs seating
so disabled people
in wheelchairs cannot use it."
But the sign at the entrance
telling everyone
that there is accessible
seating downstairs as an alternative
is like their accessibility statement.
"We've discovered that wheelchair users
cannot use the upstairs seating.
This is what we've done instead."
So how does all this apply to a website?
Well, as far as the audit goes,
you can either pay somebody
or you can do it yourself.
And the same goes
for an accessibility statement.
Sadly, I don’t have time
to go into the details
but I do want to say one thing.
Make your accessibility statement real.
What do I mean by this? Simple.
I see website after website
with an accessibility statement
that begins with a slightly pompous tone,
and it says something like,
"We fully care about
people with disabilities.
We want to ensure that everyone
is able to fully utilize our website.
It meets the following standards,
blah, blah, blah."
I don't actually really care what you say.
If somebody can't use your website,
they can't use your website.
I've got an idea.
Why not instead use this
as a wonderful opportunity
to reach out to disabled people?
The first line of your
accessibility statement
could be something like,
“We’re aware that there’s
some problems with our website
that might make the experience
more difficult for visitors
with disabilities.
But if there’s anything that we can do
to help you, give us a call.”
There's the phone number right there.
“Follow this link to send an email.”
There’s the link right there.
“Or fill in the contact form.”
Right there you're reaching out to them.
Just by doing that,
you're being inclusive.
You're going the extra mile
and it speaks volumes
about your ethos as a company.
By the way, if you do have
accessibility issues with your website,
you should give a time frame
in which you're going to get them fixed
or at least explain that
it’s not possible on grounds of cost.
It isn't about being perfect.
It's about being honest.
OK, I'd like to finish by telling you
all about a very simple test
that you can do on any website
to find out if it has
a basic level of accessibility.
Anyone can do it.
And I call it the Tab Test.
If you're on a website,
there will usually be
a row of page navigation
buttons along the top.
As you move your mouse over them,
they will light up in turn
and any subpages will appear
as a kind of drop-down.
And they may also light up
as you move the mouse over.
In other words, just by moving your mouse,
you can go to pretty much any page
on the website with a single click.
Do we all understand that?
Brilliant.
If you're blind, as I've said,
you can't use a mouse.
Instead, you use a screen reader
and a keyboard.
If a website has
a basic level of accessibility,
you should be able to select
every page and subpage
by repeatedly pressing the Tab key.
Not only that, each one
should light up in turn,
just as if you were using a mouse.
Not everyone who is visually impaired
is completely blind.
In fact, most of them have
some form of limited vision instead.
So having page navigation
light up as you move,
as you Tab through them,
helps them know where they are.
So next time anybody here is on a website,
just start pressing the Tab key.
If you do not see all the pages
and all the subpages light up in turn,
it's failed the test.
Please drop them an email
informing them that because their website
does not meet that basic
level of accessibility,
it's failed this test and they really
need to do something about it.
They want to know more,
they can do a quick internet search
and actually it's fairly easy to fix.
If you guys joined with me
in doing this one simple thing,
we all will truly be changing the world,
one website at a time.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)